welcome to Freddy Fazbear's
pizzeria this movie is basically about a
guy who gets a job working at this
Pizzeria from the'80s that's abandoned
and once inside Madness ensues have you
met them yet met who foxy Bonnie Chica
and Freddy they're really terrifying I
think they're doing their job they're
supposed to be eerie and terrifying
hello
we knew that the visibility from the fan
base was super
[Music]
high every department on this movie
played such a crucial and important role
they've had Jim Henson Studios create
these puppets and all the animatronics
had such a personality chica she looks
happy and then boom she gets really
scary Bonnie is the most
aggressive if there's a time when Freddy
should be scary or intimidating he
stands tall the movement is slow and
ominous sometimes it's a subtlety that
really sells the character there's so
much in the movie that speaks to the fan
base this is a movie that's going to
have a lot of jump
scares the audiences are in for a ride
you will be blown away it's the ultimate
popcorn
movie
[Music]